welcome to this video jammie Dodger one
of the regular opponents let's let's
play the trump on this is now more like
a Tory attack oh he allows me to play
you for okay I don't mind that this will
move like for ridiculous maybe but I'd
like to take the space always always
wanted to have space Knight f3 hmm
that's no technique right I have a nice
nice space advantage here maybe you can
play you five it doesn't
oh this is this is very passive 595
yeah this is very dangerous for black I
just have a huge center yeah probably
need to do this here Bishop e7 is gone
either form so I just retreat it's not
the end of the world have the H file
open and still I can play a five or a
fire but various of technical ideas and
this is I don't I don't believe he can
afford the luxury to do these kind of
moves maybe maybe you can but i think
this quickly gets very dangerous now
okay let's let's spend this move is he
going to Castle long really and yeah
maybe he is hmm he is
okay let's break up break open the sir
this Queen side it's very weakened
so should I am continue probably yeah
not not exchange Queens
good luck d 3 b3 stuff like that is
still has a hard time to defend this
and then Luke c1 is also also on so
so I can also take and play Queen g6
getting getting near go into a form
amazing also that's f6 takes takes
Bishop takes Queen the four is also
strong okay let's do that intending f6f
six
yeah this is this explodes completely
now it's a matter of Tempe also i'm
attacking the bishop so he cannot afford
to take a be as a temper so he needs to
take on f6 you cannot move the bishop as
the Rockets lost so he needs to take i
retake and now I thought night if five
was but he can go here I overlook that
I completely forgot about Bishop d6 okay
yeah it's still good it's still a good
position but it's not what I not what I
expected to happen not at all
so Knight e5
okay Quincy to its ridiculous no no
Queen trade okay I probably need to do
this sooner or later so it goes rock v8
I just take age six know it I don't take
XX wait fifth Quincy towards what I what
I can play trying to play against the
system porn yeah look folks is 70
okay prepare 95 this is just a very
unclean I mean I probably spoiled many
chances already that I had before feels
like I missed many things
now that's a strange move okay he wants
to play queen to d6 probably
yeah yeah not probably you wants to
wants to do that i simply i simply
played this this whole game like i did I
think that the game is still running
this is really a sign that I did
something wrong the position was so bad
for black
okay maybe maybe this this helps to
break through check a five Hanks under
cooney seven
now that's it still looks okay for what
I hope
controlling a 5-1 c5f queen bee five
it takes Queen a fourth son as a pin
pretty ugly pin check time shining check
check
check
check check check check check check game
drawn ah what the heck and I really I
didn't match because I screwed up the
recording window here well while playing
times i'm sorry i don't really know how
to how to possibly fix it i can i can do
that actually haha what an irritating
game at the end and this didn't help
that i had screwed up the recording area
yeah of course it was it was very messy
and it shouldn't it shouldn't be I mean
around here this position is just just
terribly bad for black but i didn't
manage i didn't manage probably taking
only six and 26 was the what's the best
after all the problem was i over looked
at this move i completely forgot about
it and this it's still it's still nice
for white but it's not a clear when
Jackie somehow after all this back and
forth um I got a good in position but
then I screwed it up ok I hope you
enjoyed the fight anyway